where we find berry in this film
he's just it's the awakening
it's the he's the the powers are are
still fairly new to him we find him in a
place where he's still very clumsy and
he's not yet he's not yet breached the
event horizon as it were he hasn't like
broken that limit but he's starting to
feel it and it's coming and it sort of
looms and it waits for him hey everybody
its charlie that limit that Ezra Miller
is talking about is obviously the time
barrier in the Speed Force that he talks
about like they just briefly introduce
the idea during Justice League and
they're gonna bring that home during the
flash movie but whereas earlier they
build it as flash point they've actually
changed what that movie is going to be
you may have heard about this in the
last couple of days so I'll explain
what's going on in all the news about
Batman supposedly being recast in the
Batman solo movie because originally Ben
Affleck's last movie on his contract
with Warner Brothers was going to be the
flash flashpoint movie so it sounds more
complicated than it is but there's a lot
of DC stuff happening right now so be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
there's a new round of that flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
just be a subscriber and leave a TV or a
to comment on the video I'll name a new
winner at the end of this - you may have
heard last year that they were courting
the writers of spider-man homecoming to
write and direct the flash movie they
didn't direct spider-man homecoming they
just wrote that movie but they would be
doing everything for the flash movie so
originally they've been through two
directors before and I think up to that
point they were still trying to do a
flashpoint style movie because from a
story standpoint it is like the most
popular flash story that everybody is
vaguely familiar with that you can do
the TV show did a version of it so just
a slam-dunk for the movie but what
happened is is Justice League
underperform so they had to sort of
rethink how all their movies were
connected with the overall tone of the
DC Universe was going to be so I've
already done a couple videos about all
the behind the scenes changes about how
Geoff Johns is off in his own production
company now doing his own movies in his
own TV shows but the whole idea is is
that when they signed the deal with the
new directors and they earn the right to
rewrite their own version of the script
they opted to go for more self-contained
standalone flash movie instead of
doubling down on the Justice League in
making it a really big universe spanning
team-up movie like the Justice League
flashpoint animated movie if you haven't
seen that be sure to check it out it's
actually a pretty good movie it follows
the comic-book flashpoint storyline
pretty closely it's huge you can see why
Warner Brothers would be hesitant to
spend that kind of money and do that big
of a crossover with all those different
Justice League actors so the films are
still connected but we're sort of moving
into the cameo era of DC Universe films
meaning that people will still crossover
but it'll be closer to cameo level then
like full-blown Justice League crossover
so Henry Cavill for instance I think has
two more cameos that are coming up
obviously one of those is expected to be
the Shazam movie they'll probably make
more announcements about that at Comic
Con and the Man of Steel sequel but if
you haven't seen it the last year Ezra
Miller in the actor that played cyborg
have been doing a lot of convention
panels together so it just seems like
what they'll do for the flash
self-contained movie is is it'll be a
smaller version of flashpoint there was
an expose about the new president of DC
films who's in charge of the universe
now and how they were pushing for more
of a Back to the Future feel when they
say that what they probably mean is
mostly the tone because it's like a fun
film with some really WTF consequences
so it gets really serious really fast
flashpoint Berry saves his mother
universe altering consequences what
we'll see from that though will probably
be more like what you see in the Back to
the Future movie where the picture
starts to erase as he starts to change
the past so that's how he realizes that
he's totally messed up
there are a billion really funny smaller
ways that they could cross the Justice
League characters over without having to
have them on screen for a big part of
the film like you see the picture of the
Justice League start to erase like
Superman goes away Batman goes away holy
crap what have I done so I think they
want the emotional arc of flashpoint
berry learning to be okay with his
mother's death him learning about the
reverse-flash and we haven't seen him in
the DC EU yet but because they'll be
doing a story like flash
they'll have to involve him in some way
so I'm sure that we'll probably hear
about that soon because they'll be
filming starting early next year meaning
that the movie probably won't be
released till 2020 at the earliest so I
would assume like spring/summer 2020 but
we'll probably hear more about that at
Comic Con there's also a rumor that
they're gonna redesign the flash costume
it'll be a little more comic-book II
more Barry Allen comic book versus the
Justice League version that he was
wearing that look more like armor so if
you haven't seen it I would recommend
you rewatched the Justice League
flashpoint animated movie it'll be on
that new DC streaming service all those
DC movies all the DC TV shows we'll also
hear about that at Comic Con too because
it's supposed to launch in August with
Titans so check that movie out then also
check back to the future out it's just
an awesome film in general so because
their flashpoint plans have changed a
little bit you may have been seeing all
these memes posting like yet probably
not gonna do Jeffrey Dean Morgan Batman
Ben Affleck might not be in the film he
might not be in anymore DC films because
supposedly now like the soft reboot that
they're going for is that Matt Reeves
Batman solo film is gonna be set in the
past and it'll be a really young version
of Batman like a 20-something Batman
instead of a 40-something Ben Affleck
Batman Ben Affleck still has that one
movie left on his contract so he could
show up in any number of DC films like
they're doing a Suicide Squad sequel
they're doing that Harley Quinn
birds-of-prey movie they could use them
in those obviously there's gonna be
another Man of Steel movie they just
haven't announced it yet we all know
it's gonna happen eventually they could
always give them a cameo on that but
here's the thing Matt Reeves Batman
movie is still a ways off from entering
production if they get through that
movie and say like the next two to three
years and they still haven't done
another ben affleck batman appearance if
Matt Reeves movie with his version of
Batman is successful what they'll
probably do is just not bring Ben
Affleck back and just continue with the
version of Batman that Matt Reeves is
doing the problem with that you'll
realize is is that if that movie is set
in the past then how are they going to
do Justice League crossovers with Batman
and present-day so it's going to be a
little bit weird when you have some of
the original Justice League members but
Ben Affleck's Batman is changed it's a
different guy like hey you look a little
bit different Batman what do you been
doing dear
this is why it seems like we might not
see another Justice League movie attempt
for four or five years so that like
after we get through a new round of
films they would first they have to make
successful films then they can think
about doing another Justice League film
the more time goes by before they decide
to do it again the less the chances that
Ben Affleck will come back I think what
they'll probably do five plus years you
definitely see a new version of Batman
regardless of what happens in the next
couple of years Ben Affleck has so many
projects on his plate that he's not
hurting for work so like being Batman
isn't the entire world to him it was
just something cool that he did for a
while so it's not like this is making or
breaking his career he'll just go off
and make three other smaller movies by
himself in the time it takes Matt Reeves
to get another Batman movie out but they
haven't confirmed anything yet so what
I'm expecting is is they'll just go
through Comic Con we won't hear anything
about Batman they'll only talk about
Wonder Woman they'll drop the Aquaman
trailer they might give us news about
the flash movie because they'll be
starting production early next year
it'll just see how everything goes
they'll wait till after Aquaman to try
and make more announcements about the
other movies they'll make sure Wonder
Woman is doing really good so it's one
of those situations where it's like we
have a couple of things that are working
really well we're just gonna focus on
that and let the other stuff wait till
we figure it out but I know you're all
waiting for that Superman sequel don't
worry
henry cavill talked to Christopher
McQuarrie there was a video that I did
about it it sounds like he might wind up
being the director but they're just
trying to lock down what that story's
gonna be in when they're actually gonna
make it I do have new flash season 5
stuff that I'll do a video for obviously
there's a whole bunch of Titans stuff
that's going to be dropping soon so
leave all your video requests in the
comments below but congratulations to
reverse-flash you're the latest flash
ring giveaway winner please private
message me so I can get your contact
details click here for that Aquaman
preview and click here for the new
Wonder Woman 2 teaser thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight